tél il est deux heures du matin et c'est
le branle bas de combat
les pompiers de san bernardino à l'est
de los angeles sont en route vers le
nouveau feu qui vient de se déclencher
un brasier qui a encore pris naissance
dans la végétation en haut des collines
et que les vents forts poussent vers la
vie les vins sont tellement puissants
explique ce pompier qu'ils soufflent les
tisons sur les maisons à une vitesse
folle
il n'y a presque rien qu'on puisse faire
quelques heures plus tard sous la
lumière du soleil
on ne peut que constater les dégâts une
scène bien difficile à regarder
pour tony marzolo qui habite le quartier
depuis 25 ans heureusement sa maison
juste en face a été épargné on a tenté
d'aider nos voisins explique-t-il mais
le feu était pris dans les arbres et si
vite propagé aux greniers toute la
journée les pompiers ont arrosé les
débris pour éteindre les points chauds
qui pourrait se rallumer
c'est la deuxième fois joe tonique cette
maison brûle car dans ceux de la
californie les feux font maintenant
partie du paysage automnal la végétation
très sèche le manque d'humidité et les
vents forts crie un trio infernal et
imprévisible on ne sait jamais où le feu
va frapper
et puis le problème ajoute ce pompier
c'est qu'en californie
vous avez des maisons construites juste
à côté des forêts de pins elles sont
donc très vulnérable malgré tout tony ne
songe pas à quitter son quartier qui
reste malgré les parts de la nuit
dernière son coin de paradis ici
laurence martin radio-canada à san
bernardino